James what pisses you off about the
expectations of fellow filmmakers you
know we were talking about we're all the
same until we get a studio job
I think people thinking that they're on
a higher echelon than one another it's
like if somebody's going out to create
and do you were there before doing a
lower budget movie way lower budget you
might be there again so don't don't look
down on other people I don't understand
why people do that if another filmmaker
comes up to me and starts talking to me
I have so much respect for them because
they're going out and making movies I
don't care what kind of movie they made
they went out and did it and if you've
actually made movies you know how hard
it is to see something through to
completion so don't try and act like
you're better than somebody else just
because you did it on a little bit
higher budget also I mean and we're
talking like a little bit higher budget
because the difference between you know
five thousand dollars and four hundred
thousand dollars is way closer than the
difference between four hundred thousand
dollars and thirty-five million dollars
you're closer to the low low budget
movie filmmakers than you are to the
studio picture people so know which
wheelhouse you're in and be friends with
the people there at the end of the day I
think it's important to get along with
the people in the filmmaking community
because it should be a community it
really should I mean I I love to
champion other people's films I love to
help out if you look at my IMDB I have
so many special thanks credits on
everybody's films because if anybody
ever asks me for a favor I help them out
on their film now is that because I want
something in return no but I know maybe
if I if I need a favor in the future
maybe they can help me maybe not but
it's always important to go if somebody
means your help
do it because you know how hard it is to
be in the trenches another thing is it
gets way too clicky there's a lot of
like it's like high school for some
reason like there's a lot of cliques in
this film industry
and it really shouldn't be it's you got
to have respect for other people doing
stuff I love to watch other filmmakers
movies and I will always
a free copy of one of my movies to other
filmmakers if they ask but at the end of
the day it's important to to allow these
people to thrive and don't look down on
them I know I've had plenty of great
experiences I had filmmakers hit me up I
had a filmmaker in Germany hit me up and
he had made some short films and he was
like you know asking me questions and I
looked at his short films and stuff and
they were pretty awesome and I ended up
hiring him to do opening title sequences
for me on three movies because he does
amazing opening titles and you know it's
it's look for the strengths in some of
these people and never be afraid to
blend time to help somebody out too
because if it's only a day's worth of
work or an hour's worth of work that
you're helping somebody out for then
you're not really losing anything even
if you're not getting paid you're not
losing anything because it's only a day
you can donate a day doing anything you
probably are spending that day watching
Netflix twiddling your thumbs anyway so
really you can donate a day or an hour
to help somebody out and you should if
somebody's asking you to donate like a
month and a half of your life then maybe
reconsider but if it's a day and it
usually is just a day you should do it
the other thing is you know as I said
I've gone out of my way to help friends
get cast I helped a friend get shannen
doherty in his movie she worked with me
before I helped him get her I've helped
many friends and I always go out of the
way to do that and it's important to
help each other in this community
because we are not competing against one
another when I go out and make a movie
I'm making a movie on a script that I
wrote or something that I was approached
to direct so I'm not competing with you
for a job they're not competing with you
for a job they're just creating there's
so much content being made right now
that you're not competing with one
another and and it's important to
realize that these people are not your
competition but your peers do you think
that's realistic in LA no I don't think
it's realistic in LA but it's really
great to wish for it because in LA LA is
the type of place and I grew up here I I
love LA I love everything about it but I
also know that it's the type of place
somebody will say hey I hope you have a
great day and in your head they're going
you you I wish you die
or they'll say oh I really loved your
movie and then they'll turn around and
go I really hated that
piece-of-shit movie and it's important
to really just be honest with people if
you really didn't like your mood their
movie your job as a filmmaker and a
friend is to not just say hey your movie
was or hey I loved your movie it's
to say well I didn't make like your
movie because I really think like maybe
you could have tied up some things in
the third act better or whatever it is
because they're still growing they're
still learning everybody is and I I
think I think it's important to to do
that and I if somebody tells me why they
don't like my movie I love to hear it I
don't I don't get pissed off at my bad
reviews when I get a bad review I love
to read my bad reviews because I'm
curious about what they didn't like I'm
also a little weirded out sometimes when
the bad reviews become character
assassination saying like this
you know 22 year old making movies
blah blah blah he's a horrible
human being because he was just grew up
on his parents money and one didn't grow
up on my parents money my dad never got
me a single job in the film industry
just because he worked in it he didn't
get me jobs but - I love how it's like
the most important thing about this is
that I think that these people that
write these reviews saying how horrible
you are when you haven't actually met
them they're probably like clairvoyant
in a sense so we should find them so we
can figure out like all the unsolved
mysteries of the world because if they
can know what I had for breakfast that
morning and how horrible I am as a
person then they must know a lot of
other stuff so we should really find
things out I think they should be like
mediums
you